Good afternoon. My name
is Amin huck. And uh,
when I was growing up, when I
was young, when I was in school,
I used to stammer quite a bit.
I would stammer,
I would stutter and uh,
I would trail off mid sentence.
I will not finish off my sentences.
I realize I'm not the only one who does
that. There are quite a few who do that.
Uh, but it took me some
fine too. You know,
took some time to find that
reassurance that I'm not the only one.
Uh, so when I was growing up,
I used to stay a lot at home.
I was a little shy.
I was a little result.
I would not go out and play with
other kids as much as I'd like to.
And what do you do when you stay at home
and spend more time at home than most
people do?
I remember two things very distinctly.
We used to talk a lot,
real conversations,
but talk a lot.
Yeah,
we do that sometimes when
we don't have electricity,
but we don't have that comfort anymore.
Power backup kicks in
when we used to talk a
lot about everything.
The second thing I used to do a lot was
that I used to read a lot and I used to
lead, uh, uh, a lot of
stories, not math or science.
I may have been somewhere else if I was
reading math or science. Uh, but I'm,
I'm over indexed on stories,
uh,
the same stories that you read, but
you know, I could win a quiz on,
in regil comics and down
and it was a bigger fan of
in the Gel comics then how
much, it's like a terrible,
I started off within the Gel comics and
the usual stories that we all grew up on.
[inaudible] Janda, Mama, Amr,
cheese, terracotta, and uh,
there is a hierarchy that
we all follow, don't we? Uh,
if you've grown up in India
at a particular point of time,
most of us follow that hierarchy.
You move on from these stories
too famous by even secret seven.
And then from famous five
and secret seven, you'll move
onto hardy boys and Nancy
juice.
Nancy Drews let's clap for my
friend. You know, there are a few men
[inaudible]
there are very few men who have the
courage to add and a large gathering that
they've read some Nancy Drews.
I read some Wilson Boon as well.
Okay,
let's clap for my friend here.
And I totally enjoyed reading the,
the few that I did.
And then I moved on to Westerns Louis
L'amour the callback classics and by Grade
Seventh, you know, uh,
I remember in grade 17,
I was in Kansas with La and uh,
in Kansas Medallia we had recommended
reading as part of recommended reading.
Another trick with recommended reading
is that it's not part of curriculum,
it's not part of syllabus.
Nobody's going to ask you
questions in exams based on that.
So as we say in Hindi,
there is a phrase up Kesha de [inaudible],
which basically means
read it if you'd like. Uh,
but I was reading Ramayana and this
was not a much to Catherine minor.
This was proper Rama and this was
take Romano in difficult Hindi.
And in grade eight recommended reading
was the Mahabharata and I was reading the
Maha Martha, which had my mom freaking
out and terribly worried about me.
Normal kids don't do that. So all of
deep concern and out of anxiety for me,
she enrolled me into speech therapy,
into elocution, into debate competitions,
into poetry,
the citation into the drama club,
like comprehensive
damage control strategy.
I am really grateful to her for that.
I'm very grateful to her for that because
all of these things together helped me
a lot.
And out of all of these things,
I fell in love with theater and I
wanted to do nothing but theater.
I wrote my first play and it was a copy,
I must admit. Uh, but I wrote my
first play when I was in grade ninth.
I directed it, I directed my friends
and I participated in it as well.
Uh, and if some of you, I
can see the expressions, wow,
that seems like an early start. If
there's anything that describes that play,
a pathetic might be an understatement.
And there are many people who are
walking this planet still scarred by that
experience. But you know how good
teachers are. My teachers are fantastic.
They said, I mean, what you're
doing is wonderful. Do more.
They had no idea that I would take up
their advice seriously and they will have
to suffer a lot after that.
But I,
I continue doing more and
I did much more in, uh,
in high school. I did much more
theater in college than most kids do.
And that's what I really wanted to do.
But you know how it is growing
up in middle class India,
you don't choose extra
curricular activities.
At least that's how it was when I was
growing up. Uh, and it still is the same.
We don't choose extracurricular
activities as professional choices.
We choose what our percentage is,
allow us to do and there's a
strict hierarchy there. Uh,
so to cut a long story short,
I did buy a,
did a course in business administration,
worked in sales,
and then I got lucky to get into one of
the best advertising schools in India at
that point of time and institute.
And I'm the bug and we had
wonderful campus placement.
So one of the world's best advertising
agencies at that point of time.
And even now at this point of time,
Ogilvy and Mather came to campus pick
me up and I moved to boom by advertising
Mecca and I started earning my own
salary now that I was making money.
Within a week of moving to Mumbai,
I joined the theater group
and these two tracks that I had a
deer track and I had an evening track.
They track advertising,
evening track theater,
kind of define my journey over
the next 18 years of my life.
So I moved from advertising to marketing.
I was head of marketing
for Louis Phillippe. Uh,
and then I moved from
marketing to consulting,
specifically brand strategy consulting,
go to market strategies, uh,
India entry strategy.
How do you increase your market share?
How do you come out to premium
for your brand brand strategy?
Not If these were my day tracks,
my evening tracks, what theater,
poetry as a student of
cinema and as a photographer.
And if there was any one thread that know
if there was a single thread that sort
of know combined or sort of,
you know,
that was common between both
of these tracks of my life.
It was the fact that I was dealing with
stories and narrative in both of them
and working with stories in both
of these, I realize that, you know,
we don't leverage stories in our work
as much as we can and we don't leverage
stories in education as much as we
can and with a desire to address that.
I plunged into the world of storytelling
as a story coach, as a story consultant.
And what we're going to do today is we're
going to look at business storytelling
specifically, what are the
principles of business storytelling?
How can we tell better stories about
our products if there are a couple of
frameworks that we could use and
how to build a bank of stories.
That's what we're going to do. So
let's go straight, uh, into this.
You know what I'm going to do is I'm
going to share a, we do have with you now,
it may seem at first glance that this
video has nothing to do with business,
but we will look at it with a business
lens and we will see this from a business
lens. Now this guy that you see
here, uh, he has a business issue.
He puts out an elevator pitch,
a business message and that doesn't work.
And then he gets some
help and magic happens.
We look at that and see what are the
principles we can derive from that.
And I'll walk you through business
storytelling principles that we can derive
from this film.
So let's take a look at this film.
Okay?
Okay.
What did you do to my same,
I've seen
different words.
Excellent.
Hmm.
No, I'm not an expert on
morality, on ethics of begging.
So we are going to look at
this in a very objective sense.
You know this guys in business,
he has an elevator pitch.
That pitch doesn't seem to
resonate well with the audiences.
They are just passing them by and then
the lady comes and changes the message
and magic happens.
What are the principles that we can
derive from this in terms of storytelling?
The first one is that stories
speak to people's emotions.
And we know this,
that there are two sides to the brain,
the logical side of the brain,
the rational side of the brain and the
feelings and the emotional side of the
brain.
And there are decisions,
decision scientists who've been studying
a very important question that all
business leaders want to understand,
oh, this is the question.
How do people decide
when faced with choices,
when faced with alternatives,
how do we make a choice and what swings
the decision in favor of a versus B?
If there are two candidates
for they know they are too,
too lightly can candidates for the CEO
position, how does the board decide,
uh, given both the candidates
look equal? No. From Ivy School,
from Ib School, 20 years in
business, 20 years in business,
has worked in three geographies,
has worked in three departments,
has worked in freedom.
But departments has a wonderful track
record like to like know how does the
board choose between a candidate was as B,
how do we choose between Colgate and
Pepsodent and how do we choose between
vendor a was his window be?
How do people decide?
And and decision science has revealed
to us that in almost all kinds of
decisions, the emotional side
of the brain is predominant.
And stories speak to emotions.
And I'll talk about facts and I'll talk
about numbers and I'll talk about data
and how storytellers leverage that
because you know, it's in this world,
uh Oh,
where we have more and more data,
it actually makes the rules of stories
even more important because when we are
inundated with data, where we are
inundated with information from all sides,
it's even more important that focus on
narrative because narrative helps us make
sense of that data.
So speak to people's emotions and when
you speak to people's emotions it gathers
and it results in a higher response.
But Roi is higher when you
speak to people's emotions.
The second one is build common ground.
And uh,
it's interesting that the first word
that has guy used on that poster was I,
that's not a great place
to start your stories.
But if you look around lots of corporate
stories, a lot of organizations, stories,
lot of sales stories start from I,
lot of product pitchers start from I,
this is my product, this is my idea,
this is what I have done.
I is not a great place to start because
you know, I presumes that you know,
in my, what I'm interested in is something
that you are interested in as well.
But she doesn't make that assumption and
she starts by building common ground.
And that common ground here is, it's
a beautiful day. You can see that.
And when you see that you are not in
agreement. Yes, it's a beautiful day.
That's magical watch he is doing here
is getting our audience to nod in
agreement. And when your audience
starts nodding in agreement,
you are in a better place
to sell them something.
So get your audience nodding in
agreement by building common ground.
Next principle and all storytellers use
this either intuitively or consciously,
is build contrast.
Contrast is one of the most
powerful devices in storytelling,
uh, day and night. Rich
and poor, good versus bad,
hero versus villain.
It's in the world of contrasts
that story's live and
stories evoke that world of
contrast. Now, when we worked
with new products, what we,
we have fertile ground for
contrast because new products
operate in the realm of
what is versus what can be.
Now that's a powerful contrast
between waters and what can be.
So don't limit yourself to the contrast
of the problem and the solution,
which is the typical trap that a lot of
stories fall to see beyond and see what
you can do. Uh, in terms of contrast,
in terms of exploring what is possible
today versus what can be possible in
terms of what can be done today versus
what can be done in some ways when we are
building new products,
you're building the new world.
When you're building new products,
you're building a new kind of world,
paint a picture of that world because
what you want to do is not just at a
literal level,
get people to use that product.
What you want to do is you are
selling citizenship to a new world,
to a new planet,
and you want people to raise hand and say,
we want to be citizens of that world.
So paint a picture of that world and
describe that world at contrast with
today's world.
Yeah,
you that contrast and she
uses that beautifully here.
She uses it beautifully
in an emotional sense.
She uses it beautifully when she says,
and she uses it in a positive sense.
This guy was operating from
a place called sympathy,
but she is not operating from sympathy.
She's operating from empathy.
That's a powerful position to
operate from. That guy is saying,
look at me, you know I am in
a sorry state, please help me.
But why she saying is she's,
there's a powerful flip happening here.
She is not saying how bad, look
at me, how bad I am, you know my,
my condition is really bad.
You need to help me.
Instead she is saying you have not
paused and life to think about this,
but take a moment to think about this.
You have eyes,
you can see that's a powerful flip.
You can see she makes you feel better.
And that's the switch that I'm talking
about from sympathy to empathy n and then
she establishes the fact that there was
a big divide between what you can see
but icon. And that contrast is, you know,
it's implied in the earlier pitch,
but here it's explicit.
So you need to draw and build on that
contrast. And that's what she does.
It's a very powerful tool of storytelling.
See,
when you are building new products and
telling the story of those new products,
how you can leverage contrast.
And I say this that a beautiful
definition of storytelling for me,
particularly business storytelling,
but in for for all kinds of
storytelling really is truth.
Well told. No, I'm not a
big fan of definitions.
I never was a big fan of
definitions in school,
but I like this because there are
two parts, two stories. First,
all stories must come from truth because
if they are coming from a place called
falsehood, then those two are going
to have a very short shelf life.
We've seen that with enough stories
that tried to leverage false hood.
They couldn't go far,
okay?
So so far someone has a very
short shelf life in life,
but more particularly.
So in business stories,
they have to come from a
place called authenticity.
Stories have to be authentic.
Stories have to be truthful.
They have to be based on fact that they
have to be based on data and that data
has to be truthful.
Okay?
But as we saw in this example,
truth alone isn't enough.
That guy was telling the truth, I'm
blind, please help. But it doesn't work.
It needs to be stated beautifully.
That's why truth has to meet well told
and that well-told is articulation.
That well-told his presentation
that well-told is visualization.
That well-told his use of metaphor is
use of contrast when will happens to and
and meet Strut. Then it becomes a story
which is why we've seen this in life.
It's not what you say alone that matters
but how we say it that makes all the
difference.
There are people who've said no to you
and your friendship with them has broken
and there are others who have said no to
you and you're still friends with them
and the differences,
how they said it.
There are other like I could give
you another example. There's a,
there's a boss you worked with and
during performance appraisal he gave you
honest feedback and it was
critical feedback and he
told you the areas that you
were lacking in and you came out crying
and you hated that guy and you never
want to work with that boss ever again.
And under performance appraisal.
Another guy shares the same feedback
with you and points out inadequacies,
but does it in a manner
that when you come out,
you feel so happy that you want to
work with this guy all your life.
It's not what you say,
but how you say it that
makes all the difference. So,
so look at both.
Often in storytelling we look at content,
but we forget how are we going
to communicate that content.
The way that content lines is as
important as the content itself.
It's not just the fact or the data alone,
but how you're bringing that fat
alive that makes all the difference.
So explore that in your stories and lost.
You know,
a lot of damage has been done to business
storytelling by something called CTA,
call to action.
And we try to close all our stories
by emphasizing the call to action.
But don't state the obvious when
you can see that begging bowl there,
we can see that the bar there,
that's the call to action.
You don't need to spell it out.
You don't need to tell
people what needs to be done.
And you don't need to say put $5 here
because you could be excluding the
possibility of somebody putting $20 there.
So don't,
don't get too excited by CTA.
Use it very judiciously.
You know,
CTA is not call to action is,
has almost become a mandatory and the
user like a mandatory put the mandatories
which are there,
which are required to be put in.
But think about what is mandatory and
what is not. And don't state the obvious.
Now we work, you know, you know, there
are firms like KPMG and Deloitte,
there are audit phones, right? You could
think of us and the work that I do,
the work that we do at story Weller's,
uh,
is we audit stories and
we audit presentations.
And you'll be surprised
to see how much, uh, of,
of Vias we come across in presentations
that is not required there.
One of the best ways,
you know,
easiest ways to make presentations
better is to remove the obvious from
presentation. It's not by
adding, but by removing that,
sometimes we make our stories better.
See what you can remove from your stories
and those stories will come out far
beautifully. Now, you know,
if you look at universal
story structures and say,
how do I leverage this for
the product that I'm building?
I work on a product team.
You know we are,
we are looking at this
particular innovation and and,
and we believe that this is going
to change the world. How do I cheat?
How do I take,
go out and tell the story of this product?
How do I communicate it internally
to stakeholders? How do I get buy in?
How do I get a budget on this project?
How do I buy it? You know, our,
our deadline extension on this project.
How do I tell the story of this product?
All stories come from a universal story
structure, which is fairly simple.
There's a character in a story,
there's conflict and there is resolution.
Central to a story is conflict.
When there is no conflict,
there is no story. So let me say
this again. If there is no conflict,
there is no story. One of the ways to look
at conflict as the same problem, right?
It's a simpler word is problem.
Boy loves girl.
Girl loves boy and they
live happily ever after.
Nobody seen that story.
Nobody's written that book.
Nobody's seen that movie.
But boy loves girl.
Girl loves boy and father says naive.
Yes,
shoddy may Osec team know and there's
a story there without a conflict,
there is no story.
If the quarter was had given to
ponder was what was rightfully theirs,
we wouldn't have had the Mahabharata.
If, if Ramona had not kidnapped sita,
we won't have had the law mine. If
there's no conflict, there is no story.
Now that's a universal story structure.
How do we leverage it in business
and how do we sort of, you know,
how do we take that and bring
it into the world of business?
For me it's way simple.
Without a conflict there is no business
because an entrepreneur looks at
conflict as a problem in consumers lives
and he says the flip side of that is an
opportunity for an entrepreneur,
for an innovator, for a pioneer.
And when you resolve that,
then there is a story in play and if you
can't resolve it then it's not a great
story.
So do you see this innovation and story,
business and story have the same structure
now keeping this at the back of your
mind,
let's see how you know,
let me share with you a simple framework
using which we can tell the stories of
our products, any kind of product, any
kind of innovation that we are building.
And that structure is fairly simple.
I talked about contrast earlier and the
way to paint a picture of that world is
to use something like this and
fill in the blanks and say,
imagine a world where Dash Dash,
dash what kind of a world do you envision
with the kind of product that you are
building?
What will happen in that world?
What would people do
that they don't do today?
Or what can people do that
they are not able to do today?
What do you see in that world?
Describe that world way.
Simply use contrast,
use metaphor.
Bring that world alive in a way that
is inspiring so that people raise their
hand and say,
I want to be a citizen of that world.
Let me give an example from
a non tech perspective.
Dow uh, you know, globally said that,
you know, there is a big conflict.
What does, you know, so
brands, products, innovations,
ideas have to resolve conflicts. They've
said, hey, there's a big conflict.
Every morning millions of women around
the world wake up and when they look at
themselves in the mirror,
they are not happy with what they see.
They see themselves as themselves and
And that's a big conflict. They are
not happy because the world of beauty,
the world of fashion,
the world of cosmetics is telling
them that you are not beautiful.
You are not beautiful. The lady
on Vogue, she is beautiful.
The lady on Cosmopolitan, she is
beautiful. The lady on Feminine,
she is beautiful. The radio on red carpet.
She is beautiful. The lady in Hollywood,
she is beautiful but you aren't.
And there's a big distance between
where you are and where they are.
And she sees that distance and she said,
that's impossible for me to achieve.
And when you see that in possibility
and say, hey, it's beyond me,
you feel bad about where you are because
somebody else has taken ownership of
the beauty story and said, this is what
beautiful is. Now that's a big conflict.
How do they resolve it?
Or how are they trying to resolve it?
By taking ownership of the story
of beauty and rewriting that story.
So a possible articulation
for them could be,
imagine a world where beautiful is the
body we are born with is the way I look
right now.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
well that's one kind of an example,
right? You don't need a tech product,
you don't need, sometimes all you need
is insight into what a big conflict is.
And once you identify a conflict
that is large enough for people, uh,
that people face,
then you will find a solution.
And that solution can be a product,
can be communication,
that solution can be a service.
Uh,
there are many kinds of solutions
that are possible, right?
But then you have to tell the story,
uh,
of that product for people to
want to be citizens of that world.
And you're a tell that
story again and again,
and you will tell that story and pitch
that story to really stake holders and
contextualize it to them
over a period of time.
And you have to refresh that story as
well. Now that story can work. You know,
this framework is a beautiful framework.
Imagine a world where it works
for all kinds of products.
So to give you an example from a
very different kind of a world,
you are familiar with the game scrabble,
right?
[inaudible] a game that helps you build
vocabulary. Now that's really simple,
right? You know, uh, imagine a world
where people hired Richard vocabularies.
Now that's a big conflict in life.
Our vocabularies are shrinking.
And then I go back to the
principles of business, toy dealing.
There's truth and there is well tuned
to be able to articulate something well.
It remember, it's not just what
you say, but how you say it.
We need Witcher vocabularies.
That's the tool.
Let's do retailers work with.
Look around you. Leaders,
business leaders have richer
vocabularies then followers.
Political leaders have richer
vocabulary is and followers.
Spiritual leaders have richer
vocabulary than followers.
There's a straight correlation.
It's simple correlation.
If you want to be a good storyteller,
billyo vocabulary,
build your verbal vocabulary, language,
vocabulary, visual vocabulary,
oral vocabulary bill,
but build your vocabulary right now.
Imagine a world where people
had Richard vocabularies.
You know vocabularies are shrinking
today. If you ask the kid, hey,
how was that birthday party
that you went to? Awesome.
Hey, you went and saw that flume
general book. How was that? Awesome?
Hey,
you asked Lipo or how was that awesome?
Even Mcdonald's had French fries
and above. How was that awesome?
One day you will wonder,
your fallen in love.
One day you'll hold somebody's hand.
You will see the sun go down.
You will see thousands of shades
of orange. You will kiss someone,
you will make love to someone. What
will you come back and say, awesome.
You use,
you use that word for French fries.
[inaudible] so you see you.
When
vocabulary shrink we have,
we have available,
we have lesser power to communicate our
ideas in a way that touches the heart
and we can't communicate. So in
order to become better communicators,
we need to build your be a storyteller.
Abellio vocabulary and Billy are visual.
They're all kinds of vocabularies.
Verbal is one. But you know,
explore what vocabulary you can be strong
at and build that because if you can't,
then how will you express new
ideas in interesting ways,
all existing ideas in you obese.
But that's what storytellers do.
Now when that guy had put up a board,
all he was saying was, I'm blind.
Please help. He was using two
magic words, please and help.
But we've seen so much of
that that it's not working.
So when messaging becomes leverage as
words that everybody is familiar with,
that messaging becomes blind spot and
people see it but people don't see it.
It's like cows in India, you'll see
them but you don't see them, right.
That beggars at the, at, at, at the
traffic signals you'll see them,
but you don't see them. And it takes a
foreigner to come into India and they say,
Oh my God, you got cars on the road.
Good. Good, good, good, good, good,
great. So because they see
from a fresh perspective.
And do you remember when he asked
the lady, what did you do to my sign?
She didn't make the holding bigger.
She didn't put four signs.
She is not increasing
the media spend on the,
on the messaging on the same spin,
on the same size of poster.
She,
all she did was changed the messaging.
It's woke up.
It's how we say it that makes
all the difference. So, you know,
imagine a world where people have
the power of vocabularies. So, uh,
this is from the work that
you know, uh, organ. We,
the agency that I worked with earlier and
advertising did for scrabble in India.
Hey, you do cut me off. Well, your name,
I was like goofy people,
chefs and you while you're late.
So I have to know mania. What? Oh,
okay. Okay. You take risk
losing my words.
There's vocabulary.
Better storyteller.
Okay.
That's a powerful framework.
It can be used for world changing ideas
for big conflicts like the conflict
women face in the world today.
Smaller conflicts in a humorous tone.
It can also be used for
technology products.
If we were to go back in time and since
we are at Google I and say, you know,
if let's,
let's use the framework to say how do
we tell the story of Google search?
A good metaphor could be not,
you know,
imagine a world where
people can find the needle.
You're looking for your needle,
not anybody's else's needle but your
needle in a haystack because that's what
the world wide web is. And the
worldwide web is full of search results.
But our algorithm makes it easy
for you to find your needle,
which is based on relevance, which is
based on this which is based on that Dah,
Dah, Dah, Dah. It's simple
metaphor, right? Complex Algorithm,
simple story.
Imagine a world where everybody can
find their needle in a haystack.
So see how you can use a framework like
that to tell the story of the product
that you are building that
Google is building today.
And it's building different kinds of
products and solving different kinds of
conflicts.
Yesterday it was solving the conflict
of finding the needle in the haystack.
Today it's finding, you know,
new or conflicts to solve
at, to resolve. Uh, and,
and newer stories have to be told
about those conflicts. Explore that.
Now business storytelling is not
just for products. It's not just for,
uh, it's, it's to be,
it can it still be and can be
used in all kinds of contexts,
including leadership and leadership is
not just about vision and setting the
vision.
That's a large part of it.
But it's also about building a team and
working along with team nurturing a team,
nurturing talent.
So I'm happy to share with you a story
of when I realized the power of story
when I use it during a
performance appraisal. No,
not my performance appraisal.
When I was conducting
performance appraisal and I
was sitting in my cabin and I
led a strategic team of
about seven people, uh,
and it was that time of the year.
When you look back at the performance,
when you set goals,
uh,
and you assign a number after
that conversation and one by one,
each member of my team were coming
and we were having that conversation.
Now it was time for the best
performer in the team to come in.
The best performer in the
team truly deserve this.
A very good race because you know,
he had done the equivalent
of filing a patent.
A lot of people don't file Peytons and
converting that into a business where
most of the patents are not
converted into businesses.
He had done the equivalent of
both in the advertising towns.
Think of it as award winning
advertising that critics love,
but most award winning
advertising doesn't sell products.
But this product's were flying
off shelves like hotcakes, right?
It done the equipment of both one of the
best performers, not just in my team,
but in the entire office and for
that year in the industry as well.
And it was time for his performance
appraisal and he swaggers into my room.
Callers raised,
pulls the chair and sinks into it.
Hands raised behind his head,
looks into my eyes.
Okay.
Oh, Khaki, look. And when I look
at him, it reminds me of a story.
So I sit him down and sometimes bosses
have to practice what is called tough
love.
And I tell him a story.
Now that story is from the year 1989
when two wonderful cricketers made their
debut for India. One of them retired
recently as the god of cricket.
The other one,
nobody remembers when he retired.
His name is of course what you said.
We're not commonly now for those
who love cricket and who know,
and there are many in India,
you would notice that
98919901990 (992) 199-0345 years.
Who had the higher batting average.
We not commonly match after match in all
formats of the game and in all kinds of
games. He was calling more than
than the record consistently.
That's how you get a
higher batting average.
And if you go back and listen
to commentary and export
and what they used to say,
you know, this guy commonly had a finer
batting technique. He had final shots,
election and a wider range of shorts.
But he had one problem,
attitude.
And in life we underestimate
hardwork and we overestimate talent,
but we underestimate what hard work.
And I could,
I could see a story unfolding here.
They was talent here.
Batting average was high,
but it came with something else.
And I got reminded of that story.
So I shared that story with him and I
added some more bits stored. And I said,
you know what, you know, after
many years after this, you know,
after 10 years later,
there was a guy who grew up watching 10
deluca play and he made his debut for
India and his name is William the say
well and he went on to do what Endoka
always dreamt of but could
never do, not once, but twice,
which is why he's called Sultan of molten.
He scored those tuples centuries,
not in India,
but in conditions which are difficult,
which are tailored for Bolos and
tend to always dreamt of that.
But he could never, but you
know what? And then, you know,
you Raj did something that tend to always
wanted to do but could never achieve.
Right.
Six sixes.
But if there was one thing that sets apart
then the worker from all the players,
it was as hunger for the game.
It was his passion for the game and the
fact that that many years later when he,
he was considered the god of
cricket and he had nothing to prove.
Even then he would go to the nets
half an hour before everybody else.
He would put an much more
hard work and, and, and,
and good stories like this happen
when talent meets hard work.
I told that story to my friend,
to my colleague who was working with me
and seven years have passed since then
and in seven years there are people
who used to report to you, uh,
do you have a different
relationship after with them?
Seven years later they become your
contemporaries. They become friends.
I have moved on. I do my own
thing. He does his own thing.
But I am happy to report to you
that he continues to be a 10 car.
And there are many reasons for that.
First is his own innate talent. Second,
you go to be at the right
place at the right time, but,
but he still credits that conversation
as a, as a, as a life changing moment.
And he says that,
you know,
I have now combined a work ethic
with my talent and that makes all the
difference.
So where can we apply stories and
where we are in all walks of life.
When we say business, you know,
business is not just about pitching.
It's not just about fundraising.
It's not just about telling the
story of our product, you know,
businesses also nurturing talent.
Business is also building a team.
Businesses also setting a vision.
And we under leverage stories and
storytelling in all walks of life.
When we don't use stories like this and
we don't use and we don't tell stories,
uh, where we can. So
when you go out, uh, uh,
from here and say, how do I build
a bank of my own stories around?
That's something that we can,
we should all aim for, right?
How can I build a bank of
my own stories that again,
use for various situations
for various context.
There are three sources really
that you can look into, uh,
using which you can build your bank of
stories. The first one is your own life.
Reflect on your own life,
on in, on your own journeys.
And your life is rich with stories.
So if you could give you a couple of
cues when you look back at your life,
because we must,
and we must reflect on our lives.
Leaders are reflective practitioners.
They reflect on their lives.
They reflect on their journeys,
on their strengths and their weaknesses
and their draw lessons from there.
So reflect on your lives.
Ask yourself the question,
what is the proudest moment of my life?
Go back to that and see
what made that happen.
And there is something there. Look at
that. But also ask yourself the question,
what are the biggest failure in your life?
And we've all failed at something
or the other spectacularly.
And what is the lesson we can derive
from there? And that's a story.
And you would say, hey, why would
I share that story with anyone?
But look around and leaders don't hesitate
to share failure stories. In fact,
leaders share failure stories
because if you don't share your
failure story in a business,
if you don't add Google, if you
don't learn from our failure stories,
those failures will repeat themselves.
So I say this,
that a failure stories don't go viral.
Failures go violent.
It's better that stories go viral and we
can all learn from the stories so that
failures don't repeat. So you know,
your own life is a rich source of story.
The second is there are stories in your
organization and their stories, you know,
in this company that,
that, that are there.
But we look around and there
are enough stories, you know,
stories of products that have succeeded
like anything, uh, stories of per,
of projects that were Abingdon. What can
we learn from those stories? They're,
they're better stories
sometimes too to look,
look at and learn from
stories of projects, uh,
that could not see Dale flight stories
of projects that didn't go as planned.
They were not Abingdon, they were
launched into the market but didn't work.
What can we learn from a customer?
What can we learn from a project that
worked beautifully for Emory approach
project?
Actually,
we can break into milestones and we must
have those meetings after the project
is complete. To look at those
three or four milestones and say,
what are the stories we can learn?
And then look at life all around
you because life all around you.
We are swimming and breathing stories.
Like I use a story from sport.
It's all around us.
All the story from my theology or we
can learn from other people's stories.
So these are the three sources of
stories and reflect on your journey.
Reflect on your stories and
see which story you can,
you can tell and build into
your bank of stories. Uh,
and I say there's that the best
stories come to you when you listen.
Great storytellers are
not just great orators.
They're not just people
with great vocabularies.
You become a good storyteller when you
listen because when you listen you will
get your stories.
On that note,
I'm happy to share a story with you and
many years ago when television was a new
idea,
there was this guy who used to go from
place to place selling TVs and he would
go to this,
you don't,
to up to a place that had not heard of
television and he would sell the concept
called TV to them. One day he reached a
village where you saw a strange sight.
He saw that,
you know,
every evening people gather around a
fire in the evening after they come back
from work and they share stories
with each other. He said, Hey,
you guys love listening to stories,
right? And you guys love sharing stories.
You guys will love this box.
It tells you a lot of stories.
Everybody loved that idea and every
house in that village bought a TV.
It was his best sale in months.
So far. He was so happy.
He had met his quota for the, for
the, for the next three months.
He went on holiday and then he went on
to other places and a few months passed
and he was,
he was coming back and he was passing
by the same village and he said,
I must visit this village. These people
were so nice. They bought so many TVs.
I met my sales target for three months,
so he stopped by to pay them a visit,
but he was met with a strange sight.
He saw all the TVS lying,
stacked one on top of the
other gathering dust. He said,
let me wait here and figure
out what's happening. So He's,
he waited in the village in the evening,
everybody came back from work and as
usual they gathered around the fire and
started telling stories to each other and
he went at that point of time and said,
Hey, what happened? Remember me?
You bought all those TVs
where the gathering dust
and the village elders spoke
and he said, Beta. I know
initially these boxes,
they were wonderful.
They told us a lot of stories from here
and they're from places near and far and
stories about about off places and things
that we had never visited before and
it was wonderful.
But there's one big problem.
It doesn't listen to us stories
and a lot of communication has become
like that today where people are just full
of their stories and they
want to tell their stories.
But we have no time to listen to other
people's stories. But great leaders,
great marketers and innovators are able
to lead market and innovate because they
listen to people's stories.
Not just business leaders
but also political leader.
That's how we solve problems and that's
how conflicts are resolved in the world.
Not just by telling stories but by
listening to other people's stories.
So see what stories you can listen to
and how they lead you to your ideas.
And then once you build
that idea into a product,
see how we can go and tell the
story of that product. On that note,
I'll end with a story and then we'll
open up for questions if you have any.
A long time ago.
There was an old man,
this old man had a long white
flowing beard and he had a nice,
interesting jacket with wonderful designs
and lots of pockets and wherever the
old man went, people would call out to
him, reach out to him and say, hey, hey,
hey all mine, why don't you come
and spend some time with us?
Everybody loved the old man.
They said, hey, old man,
come and spend some time with us,
have some tea and cake with us.
I have some wine and cheese with us.
Everybody loved the old guy.
At the same time in the world,
there was a lady, wherever she went,
people shut their doors and windows.
Nobody liked the lady.
The lady was very upset.
She goes to the old man and says,
why is it that wherever you go, you
are welcome. But I'm turned away.
Who are you? The old man, he destructors
hold the shoulders. He smiled and said,
I am story. Who are you?
And she said, I am truck.
You see you. Nobody likes
the truth. But she said, oh,
I'm going to make it easier for people.
So she removed her clothes and she
hoped that people would now welcome her,
but nobody likes the naked truth.
But the old man had the wisdom to
know that the world needs the truth.
So he, he spoke to her and he said,
lady, why don't you come along with me?
There's much more hospitality
than I need for myself.
There's much more a wine and cheese that
I need for myself as much more tea and
cake that I need for myself.
I can share with you,
why don't you come along with me?
And that's exactly what truth did
towards jumped into stories pocket.
And from that day, my friends that
has said that, wherever story goes,
you can find tooth
data.
The day does that.
What does that fact rapid in the
story and where will that story goes?
You'll find that truth.
On that note,
I close and I hope your story
takes you to interesting places.
Don't hesitate to share your story.
Listen,
share and gloved and male story
take you to wonderful places.
Because like I said,
wonderful stories happen to
people who tell them, well,
this is the point where I say,
I'm happy to take questions if you
have and happier if you have none.
Open House.
Yes sir.
Can you just stand?
I have lots of them. Uh,
but the uh, you know,
uh, and there are many failures,
uh, that we've all had.
Uh, one of the failures that I had, uh,
when I started the farm and I had never
been an entrepreneur before and you
know, had worked in, you
know, as a salaried employee,
you'd be know and we have no
entrepreneurial born gene, uh,
in the family. My parents were teachers.
All of my cousins are below, uh,
either teachers or doctors or employees.
And when I started off,
uh,
I really didn't know how to
build that business and I,
that's why I started story wireless.
I decided that I'll work from office.
So I hired an office space and all I
used to do was go to office and set an
operate from there.
But there was no business was coming
in and I realized that this is not how
business works.
I was expecting business to come and
just because in my mind I thought our
business has, and then I have to
figure out a lot of things on how to,
we still don't do business
development in the traditional sense.
All our business comes in, uh,
and, and knocks at our door.
But how to get them to knock at our
door is, is a big lesson that I learned.
I had no idea how to do that. And there
are really two ways of building business.
If you look at all methods
of building business,
you can put them into two buckets.
The first bucket is you go
and knock on somebody's door.
The second bucket is you get
people to knock at your door.
And I failed at this
miserably and I learned that.
So first year,
if I,
if I go and look at the first year of
business that we did at story wireless
for the first nine months,
our billing was zero.
And I loaned her the hardware.
But now that I learned how to get people
to knock at your door and sometimes
video is good because you know,
if I can reflect on it,
if you can develop on it and see
what made you fail and learn from it,
then it's good.
Thanks and wonderful question.
Uh,
us what need more precise with our means,
which is generally going to
try and to get an approval.
Most of the times we'll look for stories.
Your mind,
is there a good friends to
clean the principles that are,
maybe there's a modification to the
principals district over here and you're
trying to prove
anything.
Yup. I think the principles remain
same. The way you apply them, you know,
becomes a sharper lens. And, and one,
one thing that you would add to this
list of principles is what I call a Wifi.
The wifi is a simple principle.
Doubleu IIF, why Watson it for you?
That's a very important principle
because you know somebody's going to get,
give you an extension, not because
there's something in it for you,
because there's something at the end of
that extension period that's going to
come back to me, right? So the VP
principle is something that you know,
gets added on when we go from these macro
to the micro nuances of everyday work.
And you add the Wifi principle
when you asked for an extension,
I'm not asking something for myself.
There's something which is coming
back to you at the end of this.
If you don't give it to me, it may
not come back to you. You know,
right now I'm not in a position.
And when we walk them through that
and get them to see things from our
perspective by to the transport, uh, that,
that we are supposed to
do as storytellers, then
they will get that picture.
There's a second one which you didn't ask,
but you know,
we do a lot of work with
numbers and data and, and,
and when you apply these principles,
how do you apply them to numbers and data?
Uh,
that's,
that's perhaps another talk for
about 15 minutes or 20 minutes.
There are three or four
specific principles that help
us bring numbers and data
to life. There's somebody from
Google who's done wonderful work,
uh, Google, uh, in other market where we
would, where she's written a book as well.
She's no longer with Google,
uh,
but she's written a book on how to
tell stories using numbers and data.
And that's a good reference
point to get started.
But the principles are fairly simple.
Okay.
Uh,
the name will come back to me in a bit,
speak louder than thousand words. We've
all heard that before. Uh, but you know,
we, uh, when I speak of pitchers,
I don't just mean pictures in
the sense that we'll use to,
we used to think of them. Of
course. They're very powerful.
I can tell you a story
about how Ratan Tata, uh,
when he briefed the team four, nine, oh,
which is one of the biggest disruptions
that happened in the automotive world,
uh, before Google and
Tesla came along. Uh, uh,
that journey was triggered
with a presentation that
use one slide and one photo
in much line.
And that photo was that he saw,
he saw a family of four on a scooter.
I'm Hamare do.
And all he did was he came back,
he sketched that on a piece of paper
and he's, he's, you know, he says,
I'm not great at sketching,
but he's gets that. And He,
and he do a roof on top of that scooter.
And he gave it to his secretary and he
said, can you scan that? And he's this,
can that image and put
that into the presentation.
The Nana wasn't called an I know Nana
wasn't born. It wasn't even conceived of.
He put that photograph on the slide
and call the top management deck CFO,
head of manufacturing, head of
marketing, a head of design.
And with that one slide he explained
the target audience for whom they were
building a product. He explained
the conflict. You know,
these are people who are exposed to
elements, people who are exposed to rains,
people who are exposed to beggars at a,
and all kinds of things at uh,
traffic lights. Right? So
he explained the conflict,
but through that slide he also said, what
is the, what are the target audience?
And when you say the target audience,
he also explained to that side,
what is the price constraint?
We are not making a car four car
upgraders we are making a car for four
upgraders who are going to buy a car
for the first time scooter upgraders two
car.
And that has a price target.
And that price target
too that he explained the
materials problem because they
were not to do, to achieve that. You know,
they will have to be some innovation in
terms of materials and metallurgy and
how you fuse glass with
metal and all of that. Uh,
so he spoke to the head of design,
head of manufacturing, head of finance,
head of marketing, all of that to one
slide. Now that's a powerful example, but,
but I don't mean visuals
only in that sense.
That's one part of your visual vocabulary.
The second part of visual
vocabulary is data visualization.
How do you bring your data alive for
any two sets of data on x and y axes?
Today there are 20
visualizations that are possible.
You can bring it alive and graph
a versus graph B. Typically,
we don't explore those 20 visualization
to say which one is the best to
communicate the Wifi,
which one is the simplest.
We don't put up four slides for four
different charts and say which one
communicates. There's the
boost. We don't do that.
Typically we just go ahead with what
comes to us intuitively. And, and, and,
and developing that vocabulary
takes some time. But you know,
he just a function of doing something
again and again and you get better at it.
So that's, that's on
visual vocabulary. Uh,
and there was another question from there.
That's the last question we'll
take and then we'll stop. Uh, yes.
Well, uh, my mother, uh, you
know, when I was growing up,
we had a lot of stories,
uh, about partition. Uh,
we had a lot of stories. I was brought
up by a single parent, uh, about loss,
uh, off things and family.
Uh, I heard a lot of stories.
She was a teacher,
so I had a lot of stories about,
about how we should look at life.
Uh,
and she was a teacher in the
purest sense. No tuitions, uh,
uh, she believes, yeah. Then the,
that the best education is that you can
give during the class, not afterwards.
And if you're not doing that, then you're
not doing a good job as a teacher. So,
you know, all, all the good things that
we learn from teachers. I know she was my,
she was my first teacher.
The mothers are typically
your first teachers at home.
I have a lot of stories from her. Uh,
in terms of business storytelling. Uh,
there's this wonderful guy I worked with
for 10 years. Uh, his name is Santos Dsi.
Uh, he's written a wonderful book. He
writes a column in the Times of India,
every Monday, a Citi, Citi
Bank bank. That's the guy. Uh,
I think he's a fantastic storyteller.
I've had a wonderful working
relationship with them.
And then it's really rare that you
work with somebody for 10 years.
I have learned a lot
by seeing him at work.
[inaudible] is a wonderful
storyteller and tell you why,
to me great stories or truth well told.
And when I say truth,
well told you have to live that truth.
Embody that truth in your life.
When he told us people fly economy,
yeah,
that's not messaging.
You have to live that truth yourself.
You have to fly con me. That story
has to be evident in your life, right?
So he lived his story and he lived
life by the story that he told.
When you can live your life
by the stories that you tell,
you're a fantastic storyteller.
Thank you for having me.
Eventually, you know, time runs out
for everything, including life. Uh,
but that doesn't mean that, you
know, questions have to end here.
That's my email id. I'd love to hear from
you if you have more questions. Uh, uh,
send them in. I'm, I usually
respond to mail within 48 hours.
Have a nice evening ahead.
Yeah.